jean le mot bonjour bonjour patrice vous
êtes le responsable de la communication
de l'aventuré automobile a pas poissy
alors il ya des dizaines et des dizaines
de véhicules
absolument fabuleux on va parler tout à
l'heure mais c'est ce qui est assez
frappant c'est d'abord vous êtes tous
des bénévoles dans cette association
tout à fait nous sommes tous bénévoles
anciens ou pas ancien du groupe psa
ouais tous des passionnés de voitures
anciennes
alors vous êtes à poissy vous est abrité
dans le dans le siège de psa assez psa
qui nous héberge nous sommes donc
adjacent au site
au centre technique de carrières sous
poissy laisser des usines qui nous offre
le couvert alors pourquoi poissy
pourquoi précis en 1938 forte décide de
s'installer apprécié à l'époque il est
associé à matisse et il est en
indélicatesse avec son partenaire donc
qui cherchent un terrain et s'installe à
poissy d'accord voici c'est une terre de
d'automobiles au fond enfin poissy a
commencé très tôt d'ailleurs il en 1924
déjà il y avait les établissements
grégoire à poissy donc l'automobile et
poissy c'est une longue histoire et ce
qui fait que c'est grâce à cette longue
histoire que vous pouvez avoir une
collection absolument fabuleuse parce
qu'il est donc la forme d'abord ensuite
y'a quoi alors ford est repris en 1954
par cinca simca qui va doubler la
surface de l'usiné de poissy ensuite
cynthia et sylvana c'est quoi au départ
c'est pour importer des sortes de
d'automobiles créé par fiat c'est ça
alors simca est créée par henri théodore
pigozzi qui était le directeur général
de la saf saf saf pour importer les
véhicules fiat en france d'accord c'est
ça parce qu'ils avaient droit donne très
élevé il fallait fabriquer en france
donc il craint en novembre 34 une
société qui s'appelle cinca société
industrielle de mécanique et carrosserie
automobile d'accord et dès le mois de
février 1935 qui reprend donc une usine
qui appartenait à donnait anciens
constructeurs aussi il est situé entre
la boule et les bergers
et en juillet 1935 on commence sa
fabrication des produits issus des
technologies fiat s'appelle c'est le cas
voilà et le premier logo c'est cynthia
sous licenciable d'accord donc donc al
horford simca ensuite y'a quoi alors en
1958 simca signent un accord technique
et commercial avec chrysler réussissent
leur rende dans le capital petit à petit
on montre jusqu à 99,3 % du capital et
en 1970 on change de nom ou devient
chrysler france cristal france amateur
et peugeot arrive quand alors alors
chrysler qui a de grosses difficultés
états unis cherchent à se séparer de ses
filiales européennes et en août 1978 le
disent tous précisément il est bien on
apprend que l'aer filiales européennes
de chrysler sont aux prises par le
groupe ps d'accord et c'est là que ça
s'installe à poissy
d'accord ce qui fait que alors c'est
assez passionnant parce que évidemment
vous avez des véhicules qui datent de
les premiers véhicules que vous avez
date de quand alors dans notre
exposition le premier véhicule
c'est le véhicule particulier fabriqué
en 1946 monsieur lusine qui va commencer
enfin à fabriquer en 1939 la déclaration
hier on va avoir une période très
difficile qui va être surtout consacrée
aux camions par contre le premier
véhicule particulier c'est la forme 472
a donc c'est une hybride à la brique et
voilà c'est une forme est là c'est
amusant parce que y'a évident à bord il
veut d'abord voir ici des ford revoir
des simca on va voir avoir des ddd
peugeot mais il ya aussi des biens aussi
gêné j'ai remarqué des modèles un peu
hybride se dire qu'ils sont repris 1 les
uns par les autres par exemple d
des véhicules où on a que la carrosserie
et puis on met le moteur d'une autre
d'une autre alors ça c'est il ya un
quart cassis culié on a une talbot lago
america en 1958 la marque talbot en
faillite pigozzi la rachète prêts et les
caisses qui restait de ce fameux coupé
on va mettre des moteurs de vedettes
voilà c'est ça rit ça va être le coupé
l'agoa américain a coupé mythique
parmi toutes les véhicules que vous avez
dsk n'a dont vous êtes extrêmement fiers
et sont pour vous les plus les plus
mythiques ou le plus beau
alors est ce que tous ceux offerts
d'attachement à peu près pour tous
véhicules
il y a quand même des préférences est
pour l'instant la préférence qu'on
appelle notre bijou c'est la forte comme
ept monte carlo enfin qui a été vendue
en or à la fin sous la marque simca mais
on l'a présenté à rétromobile l'année
terme et elle est parue sur la presse et
dans tous les médias et comment alors
comment voulez récupérer ses modèles il
ya plusieurs heures
orientation soit si c'est un véhicule
que l'on cherche absolument pour avoir
une belle collection
on cherche à acheter autrement on a des
dons mais aujourd'hui les dons donne
toujours sur les véhicules de très
grande diffusion
là ces véhicules ne nous manque pas
d'accord notre
voilà où on achète ou des dons ou et
puis on a une dotation aujourd'hui est
suffisante et surnage 70 véhicules
d'exposer mais on en a trente encore en
réserve d'accord est ce qu'il ya un
véhicule que vous cherchez vous avez
vous dit tu là il manque
on aimerait bien la voir alors le numéro
un dans nos recherches
aujourd'hui c'est le break mari si
possible première génération
donc c'est le break qui a été mis sur la
génération des nos dettes s'élèvent à
galliano versailles régence et le fameux
brake parler et vedette triano
versailles c'était qu'elle marque alors
ce produit a été conçu par ford d'accord
en 1954 cinca rachète ford mais avec
mise en application de l'accord au 1er
décembre le salon de paris ce mois
d'octobre donc la génération des
vedettes versailles régence va être
présentée au salon de paris sur les deux
stands sont décelés sur le site et
ensuite les productions vont continuer
sous la marque simca oui c'est pour ça
qu'on a l'impression à vos mots qu'il
des voitures françaises vous qui
ressemble beaucoup à des voitures
américaines doit cesser ses cieux
lorsque cynthia reprend ford
l'engagement de pigozzi c'est de
continuer les activités camions et
voitures particulières de la marque
forme alors les ont créés donc cynthia
division arômes nanterre cynthia
division vedette fois-ci poissy et on
voit encore dans les campagnes des
panonceaux avec division vedette
division arômes mais les carrosseries
sont absolument fabuleuse par liszt est
forte
est-ce qu'elle marche les voitures est
là elle roule alors quelles fonctions
pour te garde tout ne roule pas maga
pour qu'un véhicule ancien rôle il faut
l'entretenir le sait retourner
régulièrement nous n'avons pas assez de
bras donc si vous pouvez faire un appel
nous cherchons des ventes chercher les
volontaires qui sont dûment dans tous
les métiers sur le fonctionnement de
l'association
c'est d'utiliser les compétences ni vie
et vous avez d'ailleurs un atelier il un
grand atelier avec trois ponts on a deux
places au sol de façon à pouvoir
conduire les restaurations et là encore
ce sont des volontaires
là encore ce sont des vélos des
volontaires les autres que travailler
sous l'eau c'est peugeot qui sont les
membres de l'association font alors au
départ l'association a été créée par des
membres du personnel mais par contre
aujourd'hui si on fait le bilan on a à
peine la moitié des membres et qui sont
des anciens du personnel
les autres ce sont des passionnés
passionné de marques disparues les simca
par exemple et ses véhicules je sais pas
ce que le mode le cinéma par exemple
vous vous en demandez est ce que vous
les voulez louer est ce que ça leur est
prêtée avons eu trouver une filière qui
aujourd'hui apparemment commence à
s'éteindre pour prêter des véhicules
pour les films ça a très bien marché et
on a fait un point l'an dernier à
l'assemblée générale
nos véhicules ont tourné sur dans
dix-huit films
il y est c'était un rapport intéressant
ce qui le concerne il ya quel film par
exemple lors des screen mauvaise fille
effectua sa boule et bill par exemple
bill et oui c'est vrai que servir nous
ben est apparu dans boule et bill
oui parce qu'il faut dire voilà ce
qu'est ce qu'il ya de formidable ici
c'est que en effet iliad et il ya des
véhicules qui sont des véhicules est
assez extraordinaire enfin des véhicules
d'exception
et puis il ya la simca 1000 beaucoup de
gens qu une simca 1000 rallye des
véhicules voilà que tout le monde
pouvait avoir quoi c'est un véhicule de
grande diffusion et d'ailleurs dans les
visiteurs y à rodez
oui il ya beaucoup de jeunes visiteurs
qui demande à être pris en photo en
disant c'est la voiture de mes parents
mais c'est ça et ça il ya d'ailleurs un
aspect sentimental vis-à-vis de ma
voiture oui alors il ya il ya quelques
musée de l'automobile en france qu'elle
est quelle est la spécificité au fond de
votre association
alors la particularité de notre musée on
appelle des ruses et oui obtient oui
c'est de gérer l'histoire de l'usiné de
poissy depuis sa création par ford en
1939 et aujourd'hui l'histoire continue
et vous avez vu à l'entrée nous avons un
véhicule 208 qui n'est pas encore
véhicules anciens mais qu'on va mettre
dans nos réserves lorsque le prochain
véhicule va sortir à poissy et remettra
la et et l'histoire continue
à partir de là les véhicules les plus
récents à part 7 208 évidemment quelques
vous avez conservé pour
le moment où elle va devenir véhicules
de collection les plus récents sais
quelle date dans notre histoire trône un
tournant nous c'est en 1978 tout c'est
une étape importante qui sait la reprise
par le groupe peugeot qui procède à
magnifique musée à sochaux donc
aujourd'hui nous conservons nous que les
produits donc diffuser apprécie enfin
fabriquer de 46 à 78 euros
voilà c'est la grande majorité à part
les exceptions d'avoir le dernier
lancement mais conservées dans les
archives ap
il faut combien de temps ces trente ans
pour compenser véhicules de collection
de collection vous même
j'ai pas vous avez une voiture non non
ancienne voiture glv un véhicule moderne
modéré démêlant mais non je n'ai pas de
véhicule ans hier parce que il ya
beaucoup de gens qui nous aident
beaucoup de collectionneurs en france il
ya des collectionneurs d'ailleurs qui
viennent vous voir qui vous pour vous
proposer de vous acheter des véhicules
alors proposé de nous acheter oui il
reste souvent la comète monte carlo et
j'ai tenu le stand à rétromobile la
semaine dernière on peut dire eh bien
beaucoup ont vu cette comète est et la
bande
c'est un exemple et vous dit richard
north 19 ans alors il ya des gens qui
vont monter les prix d'enghien non
monsieur andino n'y a pas de discussion
commence à voudrais vous annoncer ça
alors aujourd'hui notre comète pour ne
citer celle là
on pense qu'elle vaut entre 60 et 80
mineurs et quand même et nous avons le
véhicule de nos adhérents ou qu'ils
aient été estimé et je pense que c'est
une estimation bros c'est la talbot lago
qui hélas t150 des véhicules rouges 259
vous voyez des fortes et si on va aux
stands à rétromobile laissait les prix
des postes mais alors il faut dire que
voilà vous pouvez peut-être une
association donc évidemment les le
public peut venir le lundi et le samedi
enfin lundi après midi et le samedi nous
avons une personne de permanence
cruciaux nous tenons à faire des visites
guidées
c'est très important d'avoir des visites
guidées pour les groupes
on prend ce rendez vous d'accord merci
beaucoup jean lebeau